okay
um
yes
today
the more
down here
fox
there you go
so
okay
like
oh
um
thank you
off the record
yes
is
the orchestra well why wouldn't
i'm gonna bring it behind you
so
foreign
okay
hello let's test
nice
let's go
oh
this
oh
hey
[Music]
hello forsyth county welcome
patterson myself and carter barron are
the two partners that
represent the purdue campaign here in
forsyth county
now if you're like me you went to bed on
tuesday november
3rd with a smile on your face thinking
our president was re-elected
and we woke up on wednesday morning and
saw something else
if you're as bad as hell as i am let me
hear it
[Applause]
folks we had 80 percent
turn out in forsyth county to vote on
election day
[Applause]
[Music]
if we had 100 votes
president trump will be ahead right now
in georgia
and perhaps david perdue wouldn't be in
a run-off
all of you are hereby part of this
of these campaigns you are all
responsible not just for yourselves to
vote
but to make sure everybody you know that
can be registered to vote is registered
to vote and that
everybody you know votes when early
voting starts
it is your responsibility to make sure
they get to the polls
if you need to drive them drive them to
the polls if you
need to put a stamp on an absentee
ballot request you do it
we are in the fight of our lifetime
let's show up like we always do
forsyth county is number one in this
state in everything
let's show the world on january 5th
that we can get 100 participation
now before i hand it off to my friend
carter barrett here
carter's going to talk about all the
vips we have here tonight
but one of my good friends here tonight
isn't an elected official his name is
dr rich mccormick and dr rich mccormick
he put on one hell of a campaign
he worked his tail off and in my opinion
has the majority vote in the seventh
district
but he's not going to be able to
represent us in fact
we're not going to be represented at all
in the house of
representatives because of this election
and what
ballot harvesting did by the democratic
party
our only two representatives right now
are in the room
and those are our u.s senators
we need to fight like hell to keep
representation in washington and this is
our last
chance
my good friend carter barrett
thank you carter patterson he's carter
i'm the other carter
i have such a distinct privilege today
to get to
introduce some of my favorite people in
the world everybody i'm going to
announce here knows something about
winning elections because every one of
these guys
just about has run a race and won with a
resounding
uh outcome i'd like to start with um
a couple of quick shout outs uh
catherine james
uh from the lumpkin county party uh
chairman katherine where are you
thank you catherine but they're in the
back bobby donnelly
where are you there's bobby up front
bobby's first vice chair of our
republican party here in forsyth county
he's awesome
um senator greg dolezal where are you
[Applause]
if you're not sure how to help and if
you're a brand new neophyte
helping on a campaign talk to that guy
he has forgotten more about winning
elections
and i think i'll ever know so call greg
uh representative sherry gilligan are
you out there there she is
[Applause]
sherry has been a force of nature when
it comes to winning elections since she
got started back in 19
and 2014 right november
uh todd jones i'm not sure todd's here
right now but todd is
he's uh doing so much to make forsyth
county
100 voter turnout for [ __ ] parties
and his awesome awesome wife is here in
fact
tracy's out there and they're passing
around some sheets if you want to
volunteer
you back on the back corner back there
she's got the sheets
sign up log in get your emails out and
let's get to work
asap tomorrow today this afternoon
uh our county commissioners alfred john
where are you
there you are alfred alfred's our newest
commissioner we're super excited about
alfred
uh dennis brown where are you dennis
brown
[Applause]
dennis brown is maybe the nicest guy in
politics
uh and this last one i'm so honored to
get to introduce
this guy is really too good to be true
he goes everywhere he shows up
he helps out he does it all and i don't
know how they have enough time and his
awesome wife is right there
with him every step of the way dana i
have the great privilege
of introducing a true forsythe hero
sheriff ron freeman
[Applause]
forsyth county this is the way to show
up
good job guys
every one of these people that we're
going to introduce in a minute that i
get the honor to introduce
senator leveler senator perdue they're
the only
senators who pick up the phone and call
me and ask
what can we do for law enforcement what
can we do for law and order
what do you need what do you see
[Applause]
[Music]
political or not they're the only ones
that picked up the phone and called me
folks we are in a fight for our lives
we're in a fight
for representation we're in a fight for
america
and i hope that you will recognize that
and i know you do because you're here
you know we've even got senator rick
scott with us today
now i know he comes from that other
state below us
and they've got that other football team
there
okay now i went to georgia southern last
time we played them we beat them
okay but
folks these are the pride and joy of
georgia
and i want you to put your hands
together and welcome senator rick scott
kelly lefler and david
[Music]
me
[Applause]
it's great it's great to be in georgia
it's great to be around a great chair
we have uh we have 66 uh wonderful
sheriffs in our state you probably see a
couple
a couple of them on tv all the time i
think everybody is the nation knows
brady judd
so but it's great to be here in georgia
i'm here for one purpose
win these elections
so i talked to the white house just
before i came
and what the president wants to tell you
he loves georgia
he wants to make sure every legal
vote is counted
he remains optimistic uh but he you know
he knows this is a lot of work to do and
he's very appreciative of what
all of you have done to try to make sure
we keep this trip
this country in the right direction
so let me just talk about david purdue
and kelly lefler
two wonderful individuals that
respect recognize and reward
hard work
they're business people so they
understand the importance of getting
people back to work and the importance
of a job the most important thing we do
for every family is make sure that it
can be self-sufficient
and you don't do that by government
handouts you do it
by making sure people get a great job
and that's what they believe in
they've been successful because they
have common sense
you wouldn't be successful in business
if you weren't logical about what you
did they do and they care about
everybody in this state now let's think
about
their opponents you know the pokemons
are basically just puppets for nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer
[Music]
so if you vote for their opponent you're
just voting for all the bad things that
nancy pelosi aoc and chuck schumer
believe in so chuck schumer you saw what
chuck schumer said right
he said first we're going to take
georgia and then we're going to change
the country
not in georgia not today
and by the way what is their change
number one they want to pack the supreme
court
so they can infringe of our first
amendment rights
for gun rights it's not going to happen
next they want to take away everybody's
private health care option
they want the green new deal which will
kill our
[Applause]
they want to defund the police
[Applause]
that's right he'll know
and they believe in socialism
so how do we win these elections it's
votes
so the moment you can vote go
vote the moment you can get your friend
to go vote you make sure they go vote we
need to do everything we can to get our
votes in as early as possible
we've got to do this all across the
state this is
the democrats believe this is their
chance if they
have if they win the senate then
all their bad stuff they can pass
so we can win this it's the right thing
for florida it's the right thing for
georgia it's the right thing for the
country
so thank you for the opportunity to be
here now it's my distinct opportunity
to introduce somebody i've gotten to
know over the last year and she's done a
great job in the senate
she cares about you she has common sense
and she will continue to be a great
united states senator from the great
state of georgia kelly lafleur
thank you wow hello foresight
counting whoa oh thank you
love you guys thank you well it seems
like it wasn't that long ago when we
were here with marcia blackburn telling
you we were going to get the job done
we did and i am so grateful but we got a
battle on our hands right now folks and
it's
going to be a long one and first of all
let me start by saying
i am grateful and so appreciative of
congressman collins for his endorsement
we are that's right
[Applause]
we are all in this together to get this
done
but make no mistake we are the firewall
not just for the us senate
but the future of our country that's
right
and i want to thank you for being
involved we need you
this is going to be seven weeks that we
need you to stay involved
because look what's happening chuck
schumer is promising to change america
starting right here in georgia that's
right
that's right look you're part of history
you
are part of history you are going to
change the future of this country
by voting for republicans in this race
and it is going to be
so important to the rest of the country
i talk to people across the country
every day
they know you're going to get it done
but i need you to make sure that your
friends your family
everyone is engaged we're asking that
because not only do they have radical
policies
green new deal high taxes big government
open borders you know defund the police
you know abortion on demand uh destroy
the second amendment
everything like that they have radical
candidates
you know in my race the person i'm
running against
was undefined he is someone that i am
now going to tell you exactly
who he is he has supported marxist ideas
he's embraced communists he welcomed
fidel castro into his church
a communist that's right a communist
dictator who killed people he welcomed
into his church he believes that
jeremiah wright should be
celebrated as a prophet i say
god bless america god does not want to
damn america and we won't stand for that
not in georgia not in georgia
that's right but look david perdue and i
no one is going to outwork us to make
sure that georgians have what they need
that america
has the freedoms that we deserve and our
god-given rights under the constitution
so we're going to continue to fight for
conservative values for affordable
health care
for school choice for conservative
values that lift
everyone up we will be your voice in
washington
if you're our voice on january 5th
that's right
but i gotta tell you i need your help i
need you to get involved get involved on
social media
facebook and twitter you know facebook
won't let us advertise right now
big tech we gotta stand up against big
tech the fake news
communist china we are standing up for
you
but look we need you to be our voice so
please
get involved chip in get your friends
and family in and vote
early and i just want to say thank you
god bless you
god bless america and welcome david
[Applause]
perdue
[Applause]
thank you guys boy what a great
afternoon thank you
i want to thank the black diamond group
you guys stick around for dinner i think
we can make it a pretty good day for
them what do you think
i'm here today to do two things one is i
want to thank you for getting us to this
position we proved to the rest of the
country
that george is not turning blue we just
let me show you what we just did i
almost got fifty percent i've already
won this race one time
thanks to you we beat two points
the problem is we have a lot of says you
have to get over 50 we became 13 000
votes short of that
so we have to do it again and with your
help we'll get over that number
the libertarian got over two points so
we produced 52 and a half percent of
georgian said no
to the liberal propaganda that the
democrats are trying to perpetrate
on this country thank you for that what
we have to do now though
is not persuade people what we have to
do is get the vote out
and forsake county we just produced 85
000 votes we do that again
we win kelp wins i win and we stop
america
i'm going to echo what kelly
echo what kelly and rick said and i want
to thank rick scott
this is not the first time rick has been
such a warrior for our president and for
the right
this is what we have to do though we
have to tell our friend to vote
for donald trump and it may not it may
be disappointing i'm disappointed for
sure
we don't know that's going to turn out
yet but we have to make sure
every republican votes in this runoff
regardless
and here's why what the democrats want
to do you have to listen to doug schumer
chuck said he wants the majority they
got 48 votes now they have to have
her book in my seat 50 votes and then
that'll be the tiebreaker we're not
going to let that happen right
the parents why we're not going to
happen every generation faces
open the truth this is our moment of
truth we'll change the builds up bigger
hill and have two streets
four democratic supreme court
if you guys can't hear it they raise
your hand back there we'll persevere
here
here's what they want to do you've heard
it and i'm going to say it one time
they really wanted to defend the police
options
they want open borders and sanctuary
cities tell me how that's going to make
our neighborhood safer it's not they
want to reduce the size of our military
just like obama did just like bill
clinton did we cannot let that happen
just when we're standing up to china
they want to take our private health
insurance that we get from our employer
180 million people they want to take it
away from us
they voted against they would have voted
against ppp
that have saved a million and a half
jobs in georgia
in addition to that they want the green
new eagle yard
so what do we need to do it's very
simple we have to get our boat out
i'm going to ask kelly to come back up
here and stand with me
guys this is it i win she wins she
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
us to make sure that we can
make sure that we can go back to
washington and stand up
against aoc nancy pelosi chuck schumer
and all these radical leftists
make sure we can do that the most
importantly stand with us
and let's make darn sure that the road
to socialism never runs through the
state of georgia
thank you guys thank you
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go right away
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
uh
i heard
you